hi i'm conan o'brien i'm in the tbs
blimp
[Music]
so my question is how am i going to pay
for this thing mr o'brien you've got a
facebook update on the incredible new
blackberry torch brought to you
exclusively by a t
a t and t those people are incredible
you betcha we travel more right away
okay a t
those people are
incredible you betcha
get paid for that right ah no you
actually don't get paid well then i
actually get this okay it's not real
it's made of chocolate then i'll eat it
all right not good chocolate
and i'll eat it and throw it up
[Music]
yeah well then i get this okay it's a
prop it doesn't work made of wood
i'll burn it keep my family warm
that's just sad
it's mine it's made of wood
oh uses the door chuck
okay there's no such thing as a door
chip
atm t
those people are amazing i gotta pay
attention okay yeah you gotta pay
attention because a
cloud is heading our way
pretty fast dude it's gonna be here in
an hour
[Music]
conan premieres november 8th only on tbs
very funny made possible by a t the hell
was that for you don't disrespect the
dirigible